I'll come back to this if you want to
jot some of this down but let's move on
so now it's question 1 let's move over
to question 2 into parametric's 2a says
find the locus of and then they provide
you with a point the variable point and
then they provide you with these
parametric equations so what am I going
to do with all of this stuff I want to
try and find a relationship between x
and y that doesn't have all these P's
and Q's flying around ok now hopefully
you recognize when you have a look at
the Y equation there it is seeing as
that's got a P squared and a Q squared
in it then your X equation which is up
here you have no choice you must square
right in order to get P squared and Q
squared so they can talk to each other
you have to square somewhere along the
line so what I did was I did that really
quickly right I knew I had to square at
some point so I said let's just get get
it out of the way ok and I just started
to manipulate through so I could use the
information provided in the question ok
so going from line 2 to line three all
I've done is expand I saw in line three
but that PQ there is something that's
provided to me in the question yeah they
give me a value for that so I just do
the substitution as required and then
only once I get to this line do I
actually give the equation a name that's
when I call it equation one I suppose if
you wanted to you could have called that
equation one and called this one 1a and
1b and 1c but you don't need to name all
of those all those earlier ones are not
that useful to me so I just wait until I
get into a form that is um interesting
can interact with the other equation
that I've got there and then I name it
ok sayin yeah how did you do it
this line here yep yep
so wait pause for a second so you went P
plus Q squared minus two P Q and of
course that plus four is still there
okay just before just before brussels
goes on
can you see we're basically doing the
same thing but from opposite directions
okay so I started with the X he started
with the Y but he's gonna do the same
I'm just anticipating here he's gonna do
the same substitution that I did because
it's the information in the question we
had to both work with does that make
sense so you can see eventually we're
both going to get to something like
these last lines down here where we
finally get the X equation and the Y
equation looking close enough together
that we can do a substitution of some
kind okay any questions before we move
on to the next bit yeah you're talking
about that line there whoops sorry this
line here yep so you went back to this X
line up here is that the first line that
you're talking about what did you do
with it yeah so I mean this is one of
the great examples of where just like in
circle geometry you know how this
there's so many different ways you can
go out did you get there did you get
there yeah that's fine
and your way may well even have been
faster than mine I compared the number
of lines that we had this is the first
way that occurred to me and it gets
there and we all have confirmation that
we went in a legitimate way because we
came out with the same answer okay cool
alright so that was 2a let's have a look
at to B now before you have a go at to
be getting us your heads who got this
question out G B hands up straight ends
up straight okay that's interesting
thanks Paul and concerning just have a
look at the question especially for
those of you who came in a little bit
late look at the question and see what's
your strategy through that before I
scroll down and show you my strategy
what what
choosing the question tell you what
direction to go in hmm you've got a line
just any old straight line it's a
parabola it's tangent to that parabola
what are you gonna do with it so Paul
what did you do yep so sorry just before
you go on Paul so you've taken this
equation here and you substitute it into
here is that right now just remember why
is he doing that what's he gonna achieve
once he does that because you've got to
not just throw equations together and
hope for the best you've got to know why
you're like what are you working towards
if he's put these two equations together
simultaneously what's he trying to find
think equation of a line equation
republic he's looking for a point of
intersection right keep going Paul what
did you do after that
okay sir so pause for a second so what
what Paul did was he found
he went to solve four points of
intersection right because you've got a
straight line and a parabola if you've
got some random straight line and some
random parabola how many points of
intersection are you expecting probably
two right we know it could be zero or it
could be one and that's the exact
specific situation we're looking for
right so you're expecting two which is
what gives you our quadratic but he only
wants one because the question says it's
tangent okay so that's fine and then
you've got your that statement out of
that is that correct okay now
interestingly I went a whole different
path and this is one of the great things
about it right I mean we're all going to
end up with the same a M squared plus C
equals zero line but I went differently
I went through calculus so this is what
I did and poor you can tell me whether
this was faster or slower I don't know
it depends on your working okay I went
to calculus because if they say it's a
tangent right then I can make a
statement about the gradient of the
parabola at a particular point does that
make sense so let me walk you through my
my working I first had to go from here
to here I didn't x squared equals 4 iy
I'd like to make Y this object that just
makes it easier for my brain to handle
and once I've got Y is the subject then
I differentiate okay and that Trivedi's
should be very familiar because it's x
squared equals 4 iy which we're sort of
sick to death of from lockers and
parabola okay
once I had that I know that the parabola
is going to be tangent to this line at
some point but look they give you the
lines equation in what form have a look
at it look at a straight line what forms
that y equals MX plus C that's slope
intercept form right so the slope is
right there so that means at some point
on my parabola that gradient of the
parabola must be the same as the
gradient line that's what that's what it
needs to be tangent right so if they
have to have the same gradient that that
derivative is going to be equal to the
gradient so once I just change the
subject tada I've found where it's going
to intersect does that make sense and I
expect Paul we came to the same did you
end up getting that value yeah okay so
we've we've sort of come to the same
point but from different angles right
I'm not done yet though because x equals
2 am
it's nice but it doesn't get me for this
piece of information here a M squared
plus C equals zero so in order to get to
that I wanted to find a y coordinate
that goes with that right to am a M
Squared that sounds familiar doesn't it
and I said well if if my straight line
passes through that point then these
coordinates will satisfy the equation of
the line so I substituted it in and then
you just have to rearrange a little bit
to get your required answer okay Paul
how many lines have working with yours
roughly anyway seven ish so they're a
bit faster bit faster I feel like mine
is less involved algebraically it's all
very simple algebra whereas the
discriminant makes stuff make stuff
complicated because b squared minus 4ac
can be quite messy but um they both work